українські військові окупуються на
миколаївщині цей підрозділ щойно зайняв
нову позицію і тепер укріплює оборону
риє окопи ми
постійно здійснюємо спроби витиснення
ворога з його позиції я скажу що ці
спроби є вдалими і ми рухаємось
правильно вперед ми займаємо нові
позиції Ми облаштовуємо їх і таким чином
рухаємось минуло більше трьох місяців
відколи Володимир Зеленський оголосив
про Контрнаступ України на півдні тут на
миколаївщині тривають активні бойові дії
постійно працює ворожа артилерія
розповідають українські військові вони
запевняють що понад усе прагнуть наступу
адже швидше звільнення українських
територій означає для воїнів повернення
додому я би хотів завтра зупинитись
фіалки от дуже би хотів завтра побувати
в Ялті український Ялті Але я розумію що
це
не зовсім така реальна мрія Треба
почекати трошки довше Ми хочемо щоб ми
чим пошвидше закінчили ці всі процеси
але якщо потрібно ми будемо тут і зимою
і весною і літом він стояти стільки
скільки треба для того щоб
повністю витіснити ворога з української
землі наступ на півдні був не таким
видовищним і стрімким як на Харківщині
але протягом останніх тижнів на цьому
напрямку українська армія теж змогла
досягти певного успіху офіційні зведення
лаконічні але йдеться про просування на
10-20 кілометрів десятки звільнених
населених пунктів українські військові
певні їхні тактика більш ефективна і
виважена ніж російська але це не означає
що наступ схожий на легку прогулянку
боїться з позивним комендант воював в
зоні АТО з 2014 року він говорить що ця
війна кардинально відрізняється але
тактика ворога не змінилася нагло лізуть
лізуть лізуть і лізуть тобто вони на
свої втрати незважають їм нас Таке
враження що їм на своїх людей ну глибоко
в нашій ситуації іменно тут і
зараз на нашому напрямку що
кожна душа реально потрібна і
жертвувати якимось нам не можна взагалі
за словами коменданта подекуди з ворогом
доводиться зустрітися віч-на-віч проти
них підійшов до нас на відстань прямої
руки витягнув тої руки от така собі була
розвідка воїн але ми успішно
цю атаку відбили противник зазнав
таке доволі таке великих втрат один із
них
вони не встигли його забрати нам
прийшлось
його похоронити з усіма ну по
християнськи Будьмо людьми навіть на
війні от потрібно знати що тут тоже
людина хоче і ворог нам сила на
під'їздах до лінії фронту постійно
опиняються під обстрілами через це село
російські війська пройшли на початку
війни маршим згодом цією ж дорогою
росіяни відступили до снігурівки відколи
територія опинилася під контролем
України вона перебуває під постійним
вогнем російських снарядів у селі живуть
до трьох десятків людей деякі починають
повертатися адже ситуація вже спокійніше
хата була геть пані вечена це шифером
шаблонков збирав коли прийшлось
прилітали як рвонула я думав але хата
полетить я потом сразу поїхав
Я приїхав тут перекрили кришу бо дощі
починали іти Ну і так і залишився
Росія зазнала величезних втрат і живої
сили і озброєння через це Володимир
Путін почав частково мобілізацію
українських захисників та ке підсилення
ворога не лякає вони можуть набирати
кого хотіти скільки хотіти але
моральний стан їхній відношення
місцевого населення до них
їм не дозволяє бути розслабленим
військові кажуть що зброї і
припасі західних
перевинських вояків не означає перевагу
на полі бою кількість зброї противника
так суттєво більше але треба розуміти що
ми стоїмо на своїй землі
найсучасніший танк
найсучасніша керована ракета не спрацює
без людини то щоб людина нажала на
спусковий курок чи спускову кнопку
Людина повинна мати мотивації ми
захищаємо свою українську рідну землю
нині українські військові готуються до
зими для цього потрібен не лише теплий
одяг а й зовсім іншим маскування треба
налагодити логістику обслуговування
техніки військові сподіваються що
зможуть звільнити якомога більше
території поки погода дозволяє це
зробити